comme un prolongement de ces crêtes
rocheuses l'alhambra surplomb de grenade
immobile éternel
mais quelque chose a changé entre ses
murs
les files de touristes du monde entier
évanoui le brouhaha des passants disparu
les rares visiteurs savoure un moment
hors du temps
eto'o a commencé comme un cadeau de
l'avoir avec si peu de monde on en
profite beaucoup plus avec le bruit des
oiseaux de l'eau
on ressent mieux l'atmosphère qu'ils ont
voulu créer
j'ai l'impression d'être chez moi comme
c'était ma maison un silence presque
troublant dans le deuxième monument le
plus visité d'espagne
si pour nous l'année passée a semblé
interminable lorsqu'on a six siècles
comme l'alhambra c'est sans doute juste
une pause une respiration
au la longeur aliciens un genre est ce
ce qui est un complément tu vas comment
avance la restauration des musées la
méga mêmes l'occasion de s'offrir une
seconde jeunesse
il y à des lieux où il était très
difficile d'intervenir car il y avait
trop de touristes comme dans cette pièce
par exemple c'est ici que se trouvait le
trône du sultan et d'où il dirige et
toutes les cérémonies au 14e
pour alicia restauratrice de céramique
la précision est primordial
elle passera 15 jours sur cette colonne
il faut qu'on puisse voir la différence
entre ce qui a été restauré et
l'original même si le tourisme nous
manque c'est beaucoup mieux pour moi de
pouvoir travailler en silence
des trésors d'architecturé islamique que
même les rois catholiques se refuse à
détruire après la reconquête au xvème
siècle pour affirmer leur présence ils
ajoutent leurs propres fresques et
gravures dans certaines pièces comme
celle-ci patriciens tente là aussi de
retarder les effets du temps
cette fresque colorée et est en train de
se détacher de son support
un travail quasi chirurgicale
centimètre après centimètre l'oeuvre du
moyen-âge reprend vie
je passe de nombreuses heures ici alors
il m'arrive de parler au bois je lui dis
je suis là pour prendre soin de toi
alors s'il te plaît réagi
pour que le voyage dans le temps soit
totale même les légumes du potager de
l'alhambra ne sont pas choisis au hasard
la partition est une plante qui se
cultivait déjà à l'épée peaufiner tous
qu'un employé dans ces grands jardins
étaient déjà présents à l'époque arabe
et médiévale et on continue à employer
les mêmes méthodes ans un témoin et
voici les gardiens inattendue de ses
jardins cet aigle et faucons pour
repousser un ennemi qui a pris ses aises
dans la citadelle
les pigeons ont proliféré encore il ya
moins de touristes est là c'est devenu
une oasis pour eux nous on essaye de
leur faire comprendre que c'est un
territoire hostile et des rapaces que
les princes arabes faisait déjà volé en
leur temps ce sont peut-être finalement
les plus fidèles protecteur de
l'alhambra